hi everyone it's joanna here today we'll
be doing a low impact cardio workout so
we'll be standing throughout the entire
exercise this workout is great for
beginners or for those of you who are
slightly overweight and you want
something which is gentle on your knees
so try to keep up and most importantly
just have fun
[Music]
so we're going to start with a quick
warm-up and throughout this workout i
want you to just keep moving okay
if you can't keep up that's okay just
keep moving your feet
and
let's just break a sweat all right so
start by marching on the spot
drive your knee up
swing your arms forward and back
relax your shoulders good job so we are
slowly increasing your heart rate
and now just tap to the side
and tap
good job
side to side tab
so there will be some footwork as well
as arm works okay
so now let's combine
stretch it out
and in
so you should feel the stretch on your
chest
as well as your back
reach out
and reach in
and now let's switch it up
and now let's reach to the top
tap and reach
good
pull your arms back down
and reach as far up as you can
and remember another tip is to just pace
your breathing throughout the workout
okay don't hold your breath just pace
your breathing
that's one more
and just
simple much
okay are we ready so each workout will
be for 40 seconds long with a short 20
seconds rest in between so the first
workout is going to be a side knee
crunch stand shoulder width apart reach
up crunch to the side
and crunch to the side okay so choose
your option if you can't reach too high
that's okay
start low are we ready let's go reach up
and crunch
good so drive your knee up drive your
elbows down
and feel the work
on your arms
as well
as your core
good
and remember to point
your knees out
only 40 seconds long
stand tall looking good
and just breathe out
as you drive
your knees
up
last few more
one more
and march it out
okay
the next workout we'll need a little bit
of space for this okay so start at the
edge
what i want to do is go double step
tap
double step and tap okay so it's two
step with a knee tap
are we ready let's go double step and
tap
crossing over okay
opposite knee
to the opposite
arm
tap good job
are you still moving
are you still smiling
that's right that's what we want okay
let's keep moving throughout this 25
minutes
double step
tap
and reach
and if you want to
add a little bit of twist on your hips
twist
nice twist
that's one more
and march it out
good
okay
now we're going to play with different
levels so right
so what i'm going to do is start in a
narrow squat
go into a white squat tap down and reach
up okay
simple movement
yet it's going to work your entire body
reach down and reach up
narrow too wide reach up
keep moving don't stop moving
down
up
and white
narrow step
and white
are we ready to speed it up
let's go
break up the pace
and if you really want to challenge
yourself tap the ground and reach all
the way up
reach
good
reach
plus one more are we there yet
and well done
okay
a little bit of punching right now all
right so what i'm going to do is start
behind
as you come forward
punch
as you step back punch up are we ready
step forward punch step back and up
let's go
forward step
and up
forward
and up
and remember to add that slight rotation
okay
keeping your fist
close to your face
[Music]
that slight rotation on your hips
will add
more power to your punches okay
keep moving your leg up
going strong punches looking good
up
and shake it out all right now we want
to combine some punches with some knee
blocks just like the first workout we
did so watch me
punch forward
pivot on your heels all right
knee block so
spread your legs out spread your knees
out
and drive your knee up
pivot
and block
good job so a little bit of kickboxing
move in this workout as well
so remember to
pivot
and use the power
from your hips punch
pivot
and block okay
and this is going to work
on your balance as well up
good job
take it out slow take it easy
making sure that you're finding a
balance
one more
up
up and just march it
out okay
we are not stopping right now okay
we're moving on to low
impact skaters all right so what i want
to do is cross your leg behind imagine
that you're skating
big exaggerated movement are we ready
let's bring the speed up imagine that
you're skiing
down that hill
it's still low impact we're not jumping
but i want you to really cross your leg
and
swing your arms up
and down nice
big movement very good
and keep your knees
bent throughout okay
do not
lock your knees
step back
and
lift
your heels up
oh i can feel my heart racing
that's one more
march it out all right
a little bit more kickboxing movement
and a little bit of balance this time
okay so we're starting on our left leg
to begin with all i want to do is step
back
kick forward okay so remember to find
your balance are we ready step back
kick swing your left arm
okay as you kick your left leg forward
swing your left arm
and balance
on your right
leg so
find one focal point
look straight ahead
kick
as high as you're comfortable
all right
so you're not competing with anyone it's
just you
so let's go
give me your best effort remember
drive your left hand back
and this will help you with your balance
that's one more
and good job okay
shake it out now we're going to work on
our right side okay so you have to
balance on your left leg same thing
step back as you swing
drive
your right arm down okay so
are we ready
step
back
a slight step back and kick
forward
as high as you can
find that rhythm find that pace
good
breathe out
as you kick up
nice
very good beautiful kick
looking really strong feel the work
on your thighs right now
see
standing workouts are equally as
effective okay we're working on your
core balance we're working on the
strength of your lower body
and shake it out all right
still working on your left side to begin
with this time it's going to be a side
leg raise with pine chips okay
so here's how we're gonna do it we're
gonna punch
and you're gonna lift your left side
up all right so stay with me
armstrong
tap
tap
okay
swing your left arm back
feel the work
on your outer thighs
and just punch
forward
all right
keeping your right
knees
soft
move forward
punch
so it's a lot more coordination
if you want to keep it simple
just do this to begin with okay
once you've gotten this movement
let's add the punch in
swing
suck your belly in
find your balance
good job
all right so we have worked on the left
side now let's move on to the right side
same thing arms are up got your face all
the time
choose your option you can either start
with a simple side leg raise
and then add the punches are we ready
let's go so punch and just
drop
your right hand
remember
keeping
your
left
knee
soft okay
that's your anchor point
punch
kick
up good job
feel the work on your outer
thighs
[Music]
my legs on fire
a few more
[Music]
that's one more
and shake it out oh my gosh i know i
know let's just finish this round with a
simple
low impact
jacks okay so keep moving
don't stop right now keep moving
my heart is raising
let's go
simple
long
impact
jacks okay
and
i'm going to give you a one
minute water break right after this
so reach your arms up
what
an amazing
11 minutes of workout okay we have
one more round to go
so reach up
and just keep moving
we're not stopping just yet 10 more
seconds
[Music]
and
very well done
take a short water break
keep yourself yourself hydrated
and we have another one more round to go
okay and i'll see you back
[Music]
well done on completing the first round
now that you know all the movements we
want to repeat
again for the second round okay so let's
bring the pace up let's bring the speed
up let's put more energy into this round
alright so i want you to give me your
best effort and remember to engage your
core
pace your breathing throughout the
exercise so the first movement is going
to be a side knee crunch again extension
with the pot with your toes pointed out
drive your hands up crunch
down okay
that's it
starting off nice and easy
so this workout it's also great to work
on your obliques
and your arms as well don't forget about
your arms
so reach up
and really drive your elbow
down
if in the first round you can't bring
your knees as high
then let's try it again in this round
good
up
and down
pointing this out
keeping your knees soft
with a slight bounce
one more
and just
march it out okay
so we're going for
double side step
with
a knee tab okay
double side step with a knee tap
simple
you got this
now don't get confused on me let's go
double and tap
double and tap
good
crossing the opposite knee
to the opposite hand
and tap look straight ahead don't look
onto the floor
there's nothing on the floor
good trust your body trust yourself
trust that you're moving
just right
and tap
and remember
twist your hips for the extra rotation
nice looking good
that's a few more
give me one more round
double and
good
now
just march it out okay remember what we
did
in
out
tap
up okay
this time i want you to really
tap the floor so go as low as you can
are we ready in out
touch
up
good job playing with different levels
and remember as you touch down keep your
chest pointed up okay
look straight ahead keep a chest pointer
up and reach up
do not slouch your back
tap
up
good job
i am sweating what about you
let me know in the comments below how
you're feeling right at the end of this
workout okay
tap
up and just
march it out
okay
now let's move forward and back okay and
remember our punches left and right we
want to add that in so
step forward punch
step back
punch up you got this okay are we ready
keeping your arms up all the time step
forward
pivot
back
up
good job step forward punch
pivot and up
forward punch back
and now let's bring up the speed
keeping it light
punch
good job up
up
just like a fighter
looking strong
looking directly at your opponent
nice
remember use the power from your hips
twist
i want to see that move ah very very
well done okay
so same thing let's stick to the punches
but now we're adding on the blocks okay
so remember as you punch pivot
and just drive your knees up to block
your body okay you got this keep your
arms up do not drop it up
punch
block
up
up so one movement at a time
pivot twist block
block good job
yeah
looking strong
and remember
do not lock your knees okay
very good
up
up
as you block
point your knees out okay keeping
a strong leg up
up
and just shake it out
are we ready for some skaters all right
exaggerate such big movement skaters all
right so imagine you're
skiing down that slope so let's go cross
cross
and cross now let's bring the speed up
stay light on your
feet
and cross
reaching all the way up and skiing
all the way down
point your leg as far back as you can
really drive your heart rate up
let's keep pushing
you're only
10 seconds left do not stop right now
i can see the finishing line
keep going
and
done okay
this next half of the block is my
favorite because we're going to work on
our right leg and our left leg
separately okay so the first movement is
going to be a step back with a forward
kick
starting on our left side okay so find
your balance step back
as you kick forward remember
drive
your left
arm
back
you have to find the rhythm
find your own pace and once you've found
it
stick to it okay
and
just look directly at one focal point
do not
change your gaze
kick forward
point your toes up as you kick forward
and remember
keeping your right or the standing leg
bent okay
so do not lock it
and
shake it out all right
change to the other side
all right
left leg firmly on the ground now we're
moving our right side
arms up
are we ready point back kick
and swing your right arm down
you got this okay point
again i'm looking straight at you
i want to see strong
kicks
nice strong high kicks
and remember to use
the power
once more from your hips
okay
swing your body back a little
bit few
your legs pushing forward
as you kick
you're almost there last five seconds
filling the burn
two
one
and just
shake it out
all right
now that we've worked on the front we're
going to the side okay
so again starting on your left leg
remember this is your starting point
raise your leg up tap
up and tap and once you're comfortable
with it
let's add in a punch
okay
start off easy
start off slow
tap
forward punch
there you go
you're moving
and that's what we want
you're just moving nice
keep
driving
your leg straight up
feel the work
on your outer
thighs
and as you punch reach forward
strong punches
last two more
one more
and check it out
oh my gosh
my heart rate
is on
fire right now i'm at my fat burning
zone what about you okay let me know in
the comments below we're changing to the
other side
start off
right leg up tap
okay and once you've gotten that
punch
release
and tap
keeping it light
there you go i know it's burning
i'm feeling what you're feeling
but stay with me
because we're not done
punch
five more seconds
strong punches
two
one
and
oh my gosh shake it out
okay keep moving
don't stop right now
keep moving
we have one final
exercise to end this entire workout
it's going to be a low impact
jax alright
so as you're moving
just reach your arm up
both arms
and
just feel the stretch
slowly
bring your heart rate
down
okay
good job
and just like this
you are at
the end of your workout session
okay
what
an easy
fun way to add your cardio in
it's not just walking it's not just
jogging but we can make your cardio
really fun as well
alright
and just shake it out okay
don't stop moving right now
just keep moving
i want you to just slowly
breathe
in breathe out
breathe in
and breathe out
so control your breath breathe in
breathe out let's slow
your heart rate back down
all right
now just take
three deep breaths with me okay
deep breaths breathe in
out
taking all the good energy
[Music]
and out
congratulate yourself for getting this
far
once more breathe in
tiptoe
very very very well done guys amazing
job and just like this we've completed a
solid 25 minutes cardio workout you
don't have to run outdoors you don't
always have to you know force yourself
to jog on the treadmill you can do this
as your cardio as well and if you like
to watch and do more workout videos do
hop on to my youtube channel i also have
healthy recipes and nutrition tips and
fitness tips as well and let me know how
you felt in the comments below i will
see you next time all the best
[Music]
you